to be branded a racist is the worst
possible label that you can be stuck
with
in america in 2021 and i've got bad news
for my paler listeners
if you are a white person you are
a racist so pronounceth the left-wing
commentator
mark lamont hill to my friend liz
wheeler
do you i mean do you believe that do you
believe all white people are inherently
racist
so i i don't know if you're backing me
into a corner with that question but yes
i i do
uh yes yes i do and he'll hill is not
alone in calling all white people racist
this sort of a smear is accepted as
common knowledge in classrooms
in corporations in just about every
other institution in this country
the left has just redefined racism so a
definition of racism that we would all
probably accept is if you hate other
people
on the basis of their race you just you
just hate blacks you just hate italians
you just ate whatever
the left has redefined racism they have
first
redefined racism such that black people
cannot be racist
by their new definition so they'll say
racism is racial hatred
combined with power and they define
power as only being held by white people
so they're by definition
then black people can't be racist but
then they'll go even further this was
one of the innovations of this guy ibram
kendy who is a total huckster he's a
pseudo-academic who has fake
degrees and fake discipline i guess
they're real degrees in fake academic
disciplines
who has become very wealthy and very
prominent by
by selling this lie of
the difference between racism and
anti-racism and not racism he's just a
race hustler but what he is saying is
if you admit that you're a racist you're
a racist but if you do not admit that
you're a racist
then you're definitely a racist the very
heartbeat
of of racism is denial and the sound of
that heartbeat that the individual makes
is i'm not racist that's the sound of
that heartbeat
of which is denial which is the the very
heart of racism
this is an effective rhetorical trick i
don't want to say that it's clever
because i don't think it's that clever i
think in a prior age when people were
less stupid and more
more educated better educated they would
have been able to see through this kind
of a rhetorical trick
but today we can't really what ibram
kendi is doing
is it's called begging the question
sometimes people use that phrase beg the
question as if it means to raise a
question that's not what it means
it's a technical term it means to assume
your own conclusion
and so what ibrahim kennedy is doing is
he's saying
that all white people are racist that's
where he's ending and that's where he's
beginning
and the evidence of this because the the
counter example would be well what about
the white people who say they're not
racist he says
to say that you're not racist is even
further proof that you are a racist
because because admission means you're
racist and denial also means you're
racist so it's completely unfalsifiable
there's no way to get around it hold up
i'm glad you like that clip you can get
the whole episode on this youtube
channel
it's called culture wars the phantom
menace you can also get it on apple
podcast stitch your google play spotify
myspace xanga live journal all over the
place
you can also get my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
thank you for sending this book to the
top of the bestseller lists
even if the lib best seller lists don't
want to acknowledge it we'll see you
next time